saturday's national miniature golf day
and wednesday was national twilight zone
day earlier today i found a spot where
you can celebrate both
it's mini golf with a unique twist
talk about a unique twist twilight zone
mini golfer here inside valleys has
gotta top the list this is jessica
what's the object of this whole who is
this monster man here he is from the
episode the fugitive you want to get it
through his legs off those books and
into a hole-in-one okay here we go
not that i mean i need some practice
we're having a blast here kind of
playing through this whole place as
we're walking through i'm noticing so
many iconic characters from the twilight
zone definitely turn around the corner
here the pig face people where do i know
them from this is from episode i within
holder be a holder uh it's about beauty
everyone needs to look the same and the
pig face is the beauty that's it i
remember that as a kid scene yeah
definitely we all got freaked me out
you also have kiss mini golf here in
town correct that one is located at the
uh the rio hotel casino so if you're
looking to celebrate national mini golf
day on saturday you guys have multiple
options here in las vegas definitely
last hole here who's this mystic seer he
tells you your fortune here you ask any
yes or no question if the ball stays in
it's a yes if that ball comes out he's
telling you no okay so my question
i believe that i am ted florento's
favorite host on las vegas now okay
stays in is correct correct stays out
here correct okay here we go lots of
pressure we want that yes
it lies
this is so much fun jessica i've spent
all weekend here national mini golf day
twilight into a mini golf here at
valleys is a place to come celebrate
what's your website definitely sci-fi
mini golf that's s-y-f-y sci-fi mini
golf find us book us online or call us
for a tea time thank you as we wrap up
i'm gonna try one more time i'm not
gonna leave until this thing says yes
he loves playing games
[Laughter]